adelita montero hello
hello atlas how are you thank you so
much for coming on the program
thank you i'm so excited to be here
likewise
super pumped it was awesome meeting you
at anthony flores
house that was a bunch of fun that field
the energy there is very strong
yes great gathering great energy of
people
ideas that are being manifested
left and right yeah this is the time
yeah it is it is and we're going to be
talking about the warrior champion
mindset i'm so pumped
this is your unique way of
rebalancing the imbalances in peak
performers
so that they can actualize their
greatest gifts into the world
and it leverages a lot of different
techniques
we'll talk about mindfulness we'll talk
about meditation nlp hypnosis
biohacking nutrition we'll talk about
all that good stuff
by the way it may not appear so but
adelita if you read the bio
she's a four-time jujitsu world champion
and so at any point if i get out of line
she's going to tackle me
uh and and actually we'll probably
undergo some demos maybe a couple demos
maybe she'll show us a couple
things jiu jitsu eyes hypnosis wise nlp
wise maybe she'll walk us through a
couple
demos if if we're lucky sounds good
okay cool okay awesome all right
arlita let's start things off
with
your understanding of the nature of
reality who
are we truly and why does this reality
exist
i love this is like my favorite subject
believe it or not um reality the nature
of reality
so in nlp we study a lot about the
nature of reality
and when i teach nlp courses
we we really dive into the
um to the different uh modalities right
so
there's like visual input there's
auditory input
there's kinesthetic input there's all
we're being bombarded
with sensory input and
our our nervous system uh
you know it has to filter it has to make
sense of all this data and it's so much
it's so overwhelming that
it has a mechanism of uh
generalizing deleting and distorting
because if we were if we were if we
didn't have this filter we'll probably
go insane
because it's just too much yeah yeah so
you pretty much you don't see reality as
it is you see reality as
you are basically through these filters
so there's this filters
so for example if you're a pregnant lady
and then you go out on the street you're
gonna only see about
pregnancy pregnancy stuff pregnant
ladies and babies
and and all kinds of things related to
that that's
that's what you see so it's a way for
uh that we hyper focus on on things that
are interesting to us
right and so if you're interested
in um making money and you have this
mindset
of you know succeeding in the world
you're gonna go out there and that's all
you're gonna see
and it can also be detrimental if you're
misusing this
mechanism you could all you could see
it's something very negative
people that are very sad and depressed
they can look around
and only see reasons to be more sad and
more depressed
and they almost tend to gravitate
towards
experiences people and um tv programs
that will actually
reinforce that belief and it becomes
addicting because our brain secretes
neurotransmitters and gets us hooked
into
certain states so this is very
interesting
so you see what you are not
reality as it is so what do you want to
see
oh i love the ending to that so yeah
what do you want to see yeah exactly
and that's that's really
really well articulated it's a really
consciousness oriented
perspective around the nature of reality
first of all sentience
plays a fundamental role in reality
so our awareness this evolutionary
culmination the pinnacle of
human awareness is
gorgeous and it's exactly how this
reality was designed to undergo this
process
and then from that point
if you're not a sovereign
being of your
awareness of your consciousness on a
most first
principled level if you're not a
sovereign being of that
oh my goodness we are going to
encounter a lot of unnecessary suffering
and we can encounter a lot more
well-being
a lot more prosperity a lot more
abundance with that mindset
change and i love the example that you
gave because it's so
common to people in the sense of
for people especially like the example
with
car rentals usually what happens is if
once you rent like a toyota prius
and you're driving around the toyota
prius on the streets for a couple days
as you go on a trip somewhere let's say
what do you start noticing toyota
priuses everywhere
you actually notice them everywhere now
but before you weren't noticing but they
were still there
and it's the same thing with if you're
pregnant and you're walking around
and you begin to notice the acuity your
sensory acuity to that specific
phenomenon becomes
more sensitive and that's super
interesting so then now on a very macro
level with
sentience with consciousness we can
think about it like
actually this is probably a pretty uh
decent time to actually bring up this
we can probably bring up both of these
because they're both kind of good
to bring up at to explain this along the
way
that
and this is adelita's um levels of
mindset
levels of mindset and so like she was
describing to us a moment ago
you can find yourself in a victim
level of consciousness an egoic level of
consciousness and everywhere you look
you will see
people that are self-dealing to
themselves people
that are complaining people that are
ignorant people that are
not creating value into the world or you
can enter into maybe one level up a
creator
mentality where you realize that you are
sovereign
you are able to create reality you are
able to bring value into the world
so why don't you yeah walk us through
this on a deeper level because this is
already
i can tell that this is already going to
be fascinating because it's so
oriented around mindset it's so oriented
around
consciousness around sentience and i
love that about
what you're sharing with us yeah so our
thoughts are
really powerful so through our thoughts
and through our emotions we create
i have a quote and it's also part of the
slogan my website is as you
think and feel so you create
yes so what does that mean right so
your thoughts when you think of
something that has a level of energy
when you feel an emotion associated with
that thought you amplify
that thought and that becomes
really powerful and then when you detach
from the outcome
you can really create the reality that
you want
so you have to know that at some level
intellectually at first if you never
heard of it
it takes a little while for you to
assimilate maybe you're gonna hear from
different people and then eventually
it's gonna click and then it becomes
part you embody that knowledge your
becomes your wisdom
become becomes your knowing okay so
just hearing this and if you never heard
before
you don't have it down yet it's just
like jiu jitsu
you're going to go to the mat and then
you're gonna show you an arm bar and
you're gonna do it a couple times
ten times in one day you go home you
come back the next day you don't know
you don't know an arm bar and this is
very similar
so there are many things regarding
mindset
and consciousness and thoughts and the
words that we use
and all those different things that
coming together
creates our reality so we need to be
really cognizant of that
because i have a quote that says
your state dictates your fate
right so your emotional state
is constantly creating uh the next level
of
experience for you so
whether um you love what's going on in
your life or you hate it
you are the one who is actually creating
that so that's good news and bad news
if you love everything that's going on
in your life congratulations
you created that
some people find that controversial
because you know there's trauma there's
suffering there's this and that is that
but we don't know what we don't know
when we stack step away back far enough
from the point view of god and the
creator
and maybe the plurality of lives and
existence
everything makes sense everything makes
sense
so we are creating our reality sometimes
good sometimes bad when we take
responsibility all right
then we can really alter like those
experiences from good to bad to to
better and
to the ultimate which is which is the
warrior champion mindset
most people live in victimhood if you
look at the graphic
like the victim mentality
victim mentality is where i came from is
part of my story like i come from a
family in brazil and sao paulo where
not super high level of consciousness
going on there
um spiritually we didn't really go to
any
religions my parents they were a little
bit
cynical of organized religions
and i mean i don't blame them from the
point of view that they understood
it was really like the opiate of the
masses in a way
but you can't throw the the baby with
the bath water right there's something
good in there
and they just ignored that completely so
we didn't have
anything right sometimes
having a organized religion you can
get something out of it it's better than
nothing
right so i had nothing
then um if you look at emotionally
emotionally
we didn't really know how to deal with
negative emotions
we had a lot of conflict in like blaming
and
yelling and screaming we didn't really
know how to deal
with conflict in a healthy way
and intellectually my parents none of
them graduated college for example my
dad he didn't even make to um
middle school
and finally like physically and
athletically and all that
we didn't really belong to any gyms or
trained as a family played in sports or
exercise together anything like that
never in fact both of my parents smoked
one pack of cigarettes a day
right so it's a very opposite so from
where i came from
we came from victim mindset right we are
not taking care of our health we have no
level of spirituality
we don't know how to deal with their
emotions it's just like a disaster
it's a disaster but looking at it you
know
your greatest trauma created your
greatest treasure absolutely
you know i am so grateful for my parents
for everything that they've done for me
and uh because they were doing the very
best they could with what they had
and i feel like i turned out all right
you know like
you turned out really fast yeah
so i i learned a lot
uh you know they were teaching me like
what i didn't want
what i didn't want like sometimes the
warrior champion mindset
even though you may not have had that
terminology while you were working your
way out of the victim
level consciousness to creator
consciousness and to
the warrior champion mindset because
this is in a sense
a perfect story of how you overcame
such intense
traumatic aspects to an upbringing where
there was such a
a lack of knowledge of this this
yes you know i my parents got divorced
when i was
eight and it was a lot of turmoil and um
and i felt like there was a lot of lack
and this and that
and you know eventually you have to take
ownership
you know you can't live your whole life
in victim mindset just because you came
from victim mindset you know it's
up to us to to grow out of those things
and realize those things
right so it was a journey because
i felt like something was lacking
something was
missing and i felt like angry and lonely
and kind of disoriented as a kid
so there was like this huge hole in my
heart and i didn't really know
what was missing so i just kept
searching and
doing things and accomplishing things
and i moved to
the united states you know relocated to
another continent
maybe in try you know unconsciously
trying to find something to
uh you know heal this wound inside of me
this lack i felt like something
was not right the way i was
raised or grew up and i i wanted to find
what that was so i went on this quest
right it's the hero's journey
i moved to i relocated to another
hemisphere right
and um i graduated from
from my international business course
and one percent of my class
and i
relocated to a foreign country
and i got married
i had two kids to uh
a successful executive in orange county
i was living the
desperate housewives or orange county
lifestyle you know i had the us the suv
a couple of kids i had the smartphone
and like you know
the credit cards and all that but uh
it still it didn't fulfill right so how
many of
us sometimes like try to use
relationships and accomplishments and
uh titles whatever just to try and
fill this void like trying to to find
your worthiness or validation
in the world or something so it was this
quest you know it's a lot of energy
you know pouring until i found jujitsu
wow
right jujitsu was like oh my god i start
training that's like maybe this is it
you know within three months i competed
in my first jiu jitsu tournament
and i lost my first match it was at
paulie state in long beach
and i was living in temecula nobody from
my school
was competing in it i just signed up and
competed
drove up and i'm gonna fight jiu jitsu
right
i was 28 years old or something it's not
like i've done this my whole life i
didn't even learn jiu jitsu in brazil i
learned here in the us
in temecula wow so with tom cranny and
carlson gracie team and those guys are
amazing
so in three months i was able to go and
i lost my first match so i had to come
back and win again
and again and again but i ended up
winning that tournament my first
tournament i won first place was called
grappling x in long beach
but um what that taught me
is that you know that didn't fulfill it
was just another way i was trying to
feel that
all the validations like look at me you
know like i can win
and and then i and then i really wanted
to win
a world title right
and um it's it's just none of these
things feel that whole
so it was not only until i realized
that my marriage was crumbling that
you know i had to really face that
relationship was
like dead it was a dead end right i had
to really face and do
something about it i had to get out of
that relationship that was not allowing
me to grow
to expand i felt like there was it was
just disconnect
there right and um
a lot of the elements that you look for
in a relationship i felt like it was not
there
so when i saw i had to face the pain of
like
the crumbling of you know the whole the
dream
the the story that you create the life
that you create that's when
really i started to develop myself to
work myself to
learn about mindset that's when i um
i did a one-week program in northern
california with the hoffman process
heavily based on nlp and
gratitude practices and cathartic
as exercises and it's immersive one week
of you working on yourself i think it
requires that for you to
turn in your cell phone and just work on
yourself right
so that was the very beginning of my
journey
uh on working on myself and did
meditation
uh retreats and things like that
so it's been like since 2012 it's been
like a journey since i
joined jiu jitsu of learning uh
about mindset about emotions the lack
and the
validation and about codependency
right how i i didn't know that about
myself that i i
i was over giving right in the give give
give program and like not really getting
much back
and um and then i just had to really
understand about narcissism and
codependency and it's
it's a lot to learn you know like
relationship dynamics
project when you project something on
somebody somebody's projecting something
on you
and there's just so much that we we
don't know what we don't know
right so it's been it's been an
interesting journey
so once i start working on myself that i
developed myself that overcame a lot of
these patterns for my childhood
that's when i was first time able to win
a world tournament
right that was the first time that it's
almost it felt like
there was a block there's something that
would not allow us like a self-sabotage
that would not
allow me to feel worthy enough or good
enough
to step on that mat and then you know
what i'm just you know gonna do this
and if there's also a detachment that
you that you create now it's not about
anger and in your opponent and stuff
it's like they are
there for you as an instrument a
reflection of you
like there are your mirror right so you
respect it in a different way the same
with relationships and all that right
so that opponent was there showing me my
fears my inadequacies
and then uh detaching from the outcomes
like okay i'm gonna go and
do my best right and i'm gonna go all in
but then they all come it's like it's
not really important
so that's when you really over overcome
a lot so that's when you go from a
victim mindset
to a creator mindset which is level two
there on this
graphic right from a victim to a creator
a creator is what it's somebody who
knows these things embody this lesson of
like you know what we can create our
reality
you know i i'm gonna meditate i'm gonna
focus my thoughts i'm gonna
journal i'm gonna do affirmations i'm
gonna
um you know uh
focus on my goals right set goals and
stay on track
so that's the creator the creator
creator
gets things done they it's about having
like what you can have what you can
bring about in the world and that's
great
but what happens is eventually after a
while you can
have all you want and that's not
satisfying
right you can have the titles you can
have the relationship you can have the
money you can have the car
and you can have you know millions and
billions of dollars people are miserable
miserable out of their lives right
disconnected from source disconnected
from
from uh humanity and what really matters
right so
that's eventually you want to overcome
and
move up to what i call the warrior
mindset
right we graduate from creator mindset
into a warrior mindset and then now
what's a warrior mindset
a warrior champion mindset would be
somebody that
now instead of manifesting things and
cars
and girls and good looking guys
relationships the trophy wife and the
house and the
crib and you know all these things
they're great
don't don't get me wrong but
if you're if you go beyond that you can
have all that
but that's not your main intention
so now if you if you're in warrior
champion mindset
what are you trying to manifest are
virtues
um okay you're not things by virtue so
imagine
love that i wanna like if i could have
anything in the world like if i was like
if i
falls in front of god and god because
it's pretty much the universe whatever
you want to call it
and saying what do you want is an
eternal what do you want
i love you what do you want so
i would say i want perfect health
i want perfect health i want truth
i want truth for me and for the world i
want the truth to come out
i want freedom
so these are more intangibles right what
do you mean freedom i want people
to be free i believe people are supposed
to be happy healthy and free and we're
not having that right now
so instead of wanting the house the crib
and this and that i want those things
but
those things they don't exclude the
other ones
but that's not my main focus right
it's the same thing when you go after a
relationship right let's say you're
single and you're looking around on
on the abs and then you're swiping left
and right right
and then what you see it's like
sometimes it's like people that are
you know projecting that oh i have this
car i have this house and the girls are
projecting like oh
you know i have the i'm beautiful and i
whatever like you know i'm hot so
i don't think there's nothing wrong with
that per se
but that's if that's all there is that's
that's just not enough not enough for me
i think if and for anybody really
because eventually down the line
that is fun for six months six months is
the
uh honeymoon phase after that
you're just like you're disconnected
like there's a disconnection
and uh and that initial excitement that
dopamine whatever oxytocin
that runs out so it's like a chemical
thing uh
dr david hawkins talked about that he
wrote the power
power versus force which is really
tremendous
uh body of work he has many other books
but
um dr hawking says that you know
people don't they're not in a
relationship is like a romanticized
like fantasy right it's not a real
you know loving it's like you're not in
love with somebody
you in love with an idea it's like a
fairy tale of a romanticized
concept construct of your ego mind
right so then it's just it
eventually that's gonna crash it's gonna
crumble down right
so starting a relationship is starting
your life and the foundations building a
foundation
that is based on you know
values like who you really are
and what you really want so you have to
do
some work and digging in right because
it's the contrast
that that takes place instead of you
just going through life
and then just like getting hurt and not
knowing what you want and just
repeating that repeating that repeating
that same pattern
you could stop at one point like just
like i had to stop at one point some
life crisis come about right
but you could do that without a life
crisis you could just
go introspect and sin and figure out
what you really want
because we've been programmed we've been
programmed we don't know who we are we
don't know
anything about the human condition
we don't know about the essence the ego
we don't know about
after death and you know we've been
programmed and
fed these ideas and
and we don't really have an
understanding
of how to relate to others because it's
everybody is
is just kind of playing a role like
everybody's wearing a mask
so it's really difficult right so for
people to break out of that
i think it requires radical
humility encourage so these are the
virtues of the warrior
okay so going back to the warrior
champion
it's like to be a warrior think about
that
the archetype of a warrior he's gonna
die
for what he believes it's about values
right
if freedom is my value
okay there's a point that is not worth
living
okay if your freedoms are stripped out
of you
[Music]
there's a point that you have to stand
up
like a warrior and say enough is enough
right and fight fight for you believe
for what you believe
for your values for your family for your
relationship
for your spirituality for whatever
values that you
hold so we need to raise our
consciousness you know
maybe we could bring dr hawkins now uh
dr
david hawkins he was
a psychiatrist he was greatly renowned
more than 50 years in practice and
super famous all over the u.s he had
clinics
very prolific wrote so many books uh
power versus force letting go
uh truth versus falsehood
and you know he created the the levels
of consciousness
the map of uh you know the different
levels of emotion so
what he used is uh muscle testing
right in muscle testing you can
calibrate you can
you can ask uh yes or no questions to
your body
just like with nutrition a lot of
chiropractors and
and body workers know this and use
access this like through our energy of
our media
meridians and all that we can ask
questions you know is this magnesium
good for me right is this
um food good for me i used to order like
a meal prep that wasn't good for me and
then
and then i i muscle tested and it came
out like no
this is there's something wrong with
this i don't know exactly what it is and
then i
and i quit so there are things that
your body knows that you can access like
a higher level of intelligence
through muscle testing so muscle testing
is widely used
you know in um chiropractor
uh nutrition uh functional medicine and
such
so the level of consciousness he
calibrated from
from the very bottom like starting at
zero all the way to a thousand as you
can see in the graph
there and according to dr david hawkins
like
80 to 85 percent of all people
are resonating are vibrating so these
are different vibrational emotional
levels
right if we if we're gonna measure
the vibrational output of your emotions
at any given time like the overall the
aggregate
some people are vibrating at shame or
guilt
or desire anger pride or fear and
those levels right overall
so anything from pride and below
is like 200 and below those are negative
emotions
right so 80 to 85 percent
are living in that reality of negative
emotions
of victimhood the victim mindset of
blaming
a fear of the perpetration of like
um victimhood and being offended
right so this is all egoic um
constructs and patterns right that you
have to
uh grow out of in in and it's like a
letter
uh you you're climbing up this this
jacobs letter
yeah right yeah so you're climbing up so
shame is in the very bottom
humiliation when you shame somebody when
humiliating in front of people don't
ever do that turkey that's the worst
thing you could possibly do
yeah humiliation is very
low like that's the people like suicidal
and all that
right this like cyber bullying and
things like that it goes right there
yeah right so then moving up um
there's guilt there's you know
eventually there's fear
pride anger and all those things so
there's more energy
calibrates higher a little bit every
time you go up actually pride has more
energy anger has more energy than apathy
and
and despair on the very bottom right you
can kind of see that
but we don't want to be stuck in any of
those levels because when we are
resonating with pride
or with anger or with fear you attract
that to your life
you're resonating that you're putting
that out to the universe that's what you
get back
yeah yeah right that's the the reality
we create our reality but we're creating
now in a
in a dysfunctional way right and
it's it's kind of like a loop that's why
you need help like you can't really
break out of that loop
by yourself right if i got coaches
um i got classes i read
books and forever forever i'm not above
any anything or anybody and i continue
to learn right
so and it's it's a lot about
spirituality and not religion right dr
hawkins talked a lot about
spirituality versus religion because
religion is dogmatic it's man-made and
it's created
is something that is just your
connection with the divine
it's the divine spark that lives inside
of you and that has no religion
it's not christian it's it's you know
it's all the above and it's none of it
it's it's the beautiful
it encompasses everything right it's
yours it's your livelihoods your breath
right so that's it eventually we have to
surrender
all these patterns and all the old
stories
and the emotional negativity so imagine
like if you're out on the street
eight out of ten people are living at
200 and below
at the lower levels of
emotional like regulation emotional
intelligence
so if you are vibrating a higher like in
reason or
love which is more rare
what happens is those people they can't
really understand what you're
saying in many cases it's like you're
speaking you're speaking english and
they're speaking chinese or something
so it's very it's very interesting to
see that you know don't waste too much
time
right yeah don't waste time there uh
trying to translate your soul
yeah right amen to these people
so the the our job is to continue to
grow
and eventually we want to be a love and
above right
and resonating with uh everything to do
with unconditional love that's the the
surrendering
right the warrior surrenders its life
to the cause of the will of
the creator through the vet to the
values it's not it's not anymore the
warrior champion is not anymore about
what he wants but is what
is what is right to do what is he
called to do why it's it's it's
non-linear
we live in a linear world everything is
causation and has to make sense so this
is straight up from the
david hawkins it's it's it's crazy
looking from the outside it's genius
level right
so you're you're accessing like your
intuition
and that now you are receiving
instructions and you're following with
the different
um outlook in life and purpose is
completely different
right and the warrior champion is
surrendering
the thoughts the emotions the life
constantly in the moment to moment yes
right to divinity itself
wow okay so
holy cow first of all
i'm really happy that i just sat there
in silence
listening to you because that was a ted
talk in itself
that riff was a straight up beautiful
ted talk
artistic expression of consciousness it
was gorgeous and i just sat there
and took it all in and watched it i hope
other people did too
i also like a good student i took some
notes
and so i will be sharing those notes as
well here in a moment
first of all i just want to say insanely
makes tons of sense i love it when all
of the pieces click
in the trajectory of the person
and so it totally clicks your story
about your parents and your upbringing
in sao paulo your story about the victim
levels of consciousness in that scenario
your story about coming here to orange
county and having all of this
all of it made for you and still
feeling a void it's always so
interesting how
when we don't feel self-realization as
the one infinite creator
what we do is we try and fill that
void with external
anything and
it's super interesting how you
found that in your process
of yes it serves a purpose for us
all to undergo some sort of in this case
what was at the time it served the
purpose you had of a marriage
you have two children and so you bring
souls into the world and it's incredible
and
it's fun and it serves a purpose and
it's awesome
but then we also realize that well maybe
the marriage that i'm in now no longer
serves my highest potential my highest
calling
and maybe uh given all of the strategies
that you went through
uh in how uh couples
undergo these styles of dynamics and
undergoing you got triggered to go into
nlp you got triggered to go into jiu
jitsu
but you know when the knocks came knock
knock
knock knock you answered and you said
i'm in
and when you say i'm in because i want
to change something because it feels
weird being in this victim consciousness
it feels weird being in something that
feels like it shouldn't be there in the
sense of i feel
something that's deeper something that's
more profound something that's maybe a
state
of of possible potential
perpetual bliss and peace
that i should be rather than something
that is
of a state of victim consciousness and
so you answer these knocks
you get exposed to more and more of
these
of these leaders and fields
and attaining mastery in them
synthesizing the core concepts
into your own warrior champion mindset
teaching that in many ways mirrors
what i would argue as the
greatest levels of genius
in the category of human development
because whether you look at david
hawkins
here and his levels of consciousness or
whether you look at
the claire graves don beck chris cowan
spiral dynamics levels of consciousness
ken wilbur jean piaget lawrence kohlberg
sri aurobindo the mother mira alfassa
eric erickson there's
a ridiculous amount of people that have
now
studied these specific levels
of consciousness and they're
very interestingly
super duper similar in many ways which
is
generally speaking they're evolving
from an egoic level of consciousness
to what the spiritual
mystic traditions call a non-dual level
of consciousness
and so what is
fascinating is that there's all these
levels in between them
and in this case with david hawkins
david hawkins does a really good job at
he uses a lot of
adjectives he uses a lot of descriptors
he uses a lot of
of ways of
perceiving oneself that if i'm attached
if someone attaches the word
you know anger or fear to me um
i think that's a really powerful i think
way
to or if i even self-reflect myself and
that's even
better and if i realize myself that oh
well that was a
maybe a little bit more of a i really
felt
the tendency of fear bubbled up in me
and so there's that's
there's like the possibility of it
getting
someone saying it to you or you
realizing it yourself about yourself
and i think these descriptors are really
helpful because it kind of gives us some
sort of a transcendent noble aim it
gives us a
a direction that like i want to be
courageous
i want to be loving unconditional loving
i
want to have an imperturbable peace
and causeless joy i want to feel
what enlightenment is i want to feel a
union with god a union
with the one infinite creator i want to
feel what the planetary mystic
traditions like you indicated
spirituality
being transcendent of the religious
dogmas and fundamentalism
i want to feel what that is and so
you know one of the great paradoxes and
enigmas
of our creation is like rumi says you go
around from room to room looking for the
diamond necklace that is already around
your neck
so you are already it but you have to
recognize that you're it and in this
case if you're down
in you know fear and guilt and shame
and egoic levels of consciousness to
just
breeze that off and say that oh i'm
already it great
so you so there's still a process that
unfolds and you can recognize you can
undergo some direct path teaching to get
yourself to realize
a more enlightened peaceful blissful
joyful
state of being but even with the direct
path
there are typically levels of
re-baselining that occur
as well along the way but that's that's
generally speaking what this is it's a
process of re-baselining yourself
over time to higher levels of
consciousness as all of the great
human development synthesis have
indicated you
fit right in at that level of genius of
identifying that we must go
beyond victim level consciousness to
creator level consciousness
and then to the warrior champion
mindset i love it it's beautiful and
i'll share these notes
because i think these notes were really
profoundly
important for me so uh first is we have
i love this one state dictates
fate profound so simple
and then take responsibility take
responsibility of your state which will
dictate your fate
and then at that very peak instead of
pursuing
conspicuous consumption of materialism
manifest virtues if you manifest
things like you want to be in service to
bringing people value
around the planet be in service to
unconditional love be in service to
bringing a transcendent noble north star
into our world what will happen is
you will manifest the
material goods in a way that
on the journey in a way that is actually
long-lasting
and the same thing's true with
partnerships like you indicated as well
that if you're manifesting virtues that
that's going to be
what ends up being more longer lasting
it's like when you undergo the divine
union with another partner
and if you're both at that level of
warrior champion mindset of your
manifesting virtues
it's unbelievable the ascension that
happens between two people
yes and jesus said is said it best right
he said
first seek the kingdom of god and all
things
other things will be added on to you
and that's so true yeah exactly the
relationship
the amazing divine union relationship
that we can only like
dream about it actually does manifest
the money the prosperity the health the
joy the creativity
being at the right place at the right
time those things are very real
but you can't experience those if you
don't even know that that's possible
yeah and then once you know that's
possible what do i need to do to align
my vibration my emotion and my thoughts
so i can actually align with that energy
so if you want
unconditional love you have to be
unconditionally loving
if you wanna if you wanna be in a
relationship first you need to have a
relationship with yourself and with god
and then with yourself
before you get in relationship in love
with anybody amen
so one step at a time yeah this is again
a very perennial spiritual mystic
truth is that the kingdom of god is
within you
like leo tolstoy said like
in john 10 30 you have i and my father
are one
in the sufi metaphysics you have
which means the unity of all unveiling
and
finding of all of sentience
which is crazy beautiful
you have the non-dual spiritual
traditions around the planet that
make it very clear that the atman and
the brahmana are
one the advaita vedanta tradition
and the more that we
go from that self-realization
and then to everything else
is when we really succeed at life
because once you really know that that
diamond necklace is truly around your
neck
once you really know that everything you
do from there
relationships self-actualization
in terms of business success in terms of
monetary success in terms of material
success in terms of
solving the sustainable development
goals in terms of everything that you
touch
with your friendships your colleagues
everything
is gold but it has to come from a place
of self-realization first
and that means that you have to work
your way you have to work your way
into re-baselining yourself to these
elevated levels of
of consciousness okay and then the last
note that was very profound from what
you were teaching
was that all problem
is disconnection from source
i love that one all problem is this
disconnection from source
and then as david hawkins used like you
indicated muscle tests
to indicate where people are at and then
as we talk about a lot on the program is
we can sort of use these biometrics
in order to
indicate where people are at on their
journeys
and i thought it was really interesting
because a lot of the things that you
were
talking about
in the last segments
we're very very um profoundly aligned
well first first thing is that i just
like to
say that it was really cool how you used
the analogy of don't throw the baby out
with the bathwater
because that's a such a core analogy of
my life
this is in chapter seven it's called the
sorting algorithm that you want to
that you want to retain the beautiful
baby of spirituality as you drain the
dirty bath water of religious
fundamentalism
and dogma and then the same thing with
science on the other side is that you
want to keep
the beauty of the scientific method but
then you want to drain a lot of the
perverse incentives that exist
in the sciences as well and then marry
the two babies into one science and
spirituality
so there's that one and then there's
this other one
which we were just talking about a
moment ago which is the idea
of some sort of a biometrics of
awakening
so if we can use david hawkins if we can
use
the other sort of leaders in the space
of quantifying
biometrically via eeg fmri
hrv microbiome all of the different
quantified self movements in biohacking
if i can say that
you rank on this specific spot on the
human development index let's say and
then
we can do interventions around
meditation mindfulness hypnosis
uh entheogens uh all different types of
nutrition
nutrition sleep exactly awareness
consciousness being a sovereign being in
that sense
self-realization that we can re-baseline
people
up towards more enlightened states of
consciousness
and this becomes really important
because
if we do this for as you see there
there's one that's a wealth hierarchy
and then there's the other that's an
enlightenment hierarchy
we always put people into a wealth
hierarchy and we never put people into
an enlightenment hierarchy
and it's interesting because what if you
take the people at the top of the wealth
hierarchy like the 2
200 billionaires around the planet or
the
the 225 000 ultra high net worth people
around the planet or the un general
assembly assembly or the fortune 500
ceos or the usa congress
and what if we begin quantifying them on
the human development index
what if our most powerful people in
positions of leadership around the
country
are in egoic levels of consciousness
we'll call it sub 200 right they're
below 200 and below you can see just by
discernment of the the words and the
acts that they
actually do not what they say they're
going to do
and one more time sub 200 is pride in
below is that right
yes so pride and below those are
negative levels of negative emotions
is sub 200 sub 200. so and it goes from
zero to zero
enlightenment it's like a thousand got
it you pretty much when you reach that
you just
you can't hold that vibration um
in the planet like people just just yeah
go away there's nothing for them
to do i have totally started feeling
vibes like that and it has been ex
most profound experiences of my life so
far moment to moment
is just like insane it's incredible
and um i can help
people like you can and like so many of
our guests come that come on the program
is we try and help provide
viewers with the materials
that are needed in order to make these
upgrades
in consciousness that's the whole point
of the [ __ ] show
welcome to simulation yeah so
i i love i love this i love this
it's such a great way to visualize but
we have to be honest
that's something we have to be honest
with ourselves with where we're at
and we have to also be
willing willingness is a big one
willingness right in there
courage courage it takes so much courage
right
um when i was feeling like was strapped
in
in the marriage into that kind of so so
shy
so societal construct
is it's it's really difficult for you to
say you know what i'm gonna blow this
thing up and i'm gonna
go after like what my heart is saying
that's what i said i'm following my
heart so i was
scoffed at left that i was diagnosed as
a nor with narcissistic personality
disorder
so i start feeling anxiety and panic
because i start to
buy into that it's like well maybe maybe
they are right because this is like my
ex with together with
our therapists and they're like together
like saying that you know i am a thera
um i
i have a narcissistic personality
disorder
and buying a narcissistic disorder book
and giving it to my 15 year old son
and it's like here's how you deal with
your mom and then i start like
buying to that so it's very dangerous
when you go
see somebody and and then you take
what they say just because they're the
expert on the other side at face value
so i started to believe
that i maybe i was that and i started to
have panic attacks
i never had before so one day i i don't
really tell my mom
everything that goes on in my life
because there's nothing she can do she's
another part of the world she doesn't
speak
english she you know it's just there's
there's not much that she can do and
she's kind of frail like emotionally
let's say so i i kind of spare her and i
filter a lot of stuff
so i but eventually i you know i i was
i was uh sharing with her what was going
what was happening and what they said
and she said adelita
you forgot who you are just the fact
that you considering
whether or not you are a narcissist that
means you're not a narcissist
number one second is
narcissistic personality disorder people
they have no remorse they have no
empathy
all they do is they manipulate their all
all about themselves
and all i've
we've known you growing up what you do
is like you're always helping people
like you can't help yourself but
like reach out and without people asking
for your help you're already helping you
were very involved and
um and and then she
she kind of made something click inside
my head i was like
and snapped me out of this trance right
and i was being hypnotized
so eventually when i realized that
and and i saw what was going on i said
you know what
this is my truth this is when i'm out of
this has gotta
this is done you know i came back from
the huffman process it was crystal clear
what i had to do
i actually had a vision that came to me
it was like
kind of like uh because we do a lot of
gratitude and a lot of
a little bit some spiritual work too so
in my dream
the weekend of uh the end of that
that event i saw like
my ex and there was like a sword that
was pushing on his belly just a little
bit
and from what i understood what i felt
in that moment of that image
is that i was the warrior the samurai
that had to go and push it in all the
way because
he was already in pain he was already
suffering
so that that's what just what i had to
do and that's what i did
so i just pushed the sword all the way
in
like with that um samurai
like uh empathy and respect for your
for your opponent's death right in a
sacred way
right nor in a anger revengeful way
but it's like put you out of your misery
right
so that's exactly what i did when i and
then i had it very
very clear like as soon as you go back
do not hesitate don't wait as soon as
you come back from this
retreat let him know tell him that's
done and that it's over
and it's this egg and just put him out
of the out of the misery right
and then i arrived on a sunday was
father's day i felt like um
spirit really like i don't think that's
uh
maybe i'll wait until monday morning
monday morning
so monday morning came and
and then i told him so i said you know
that's it i do
you know maybe it's gonna take a little
process of time but it's like it's like
i'm just
i'm just done we're done that's it i'm
done right
so we're already living like roommates
for like almost like a year before that
already so it's like somebody had to do
something who's gonna like push the
sword in
right who's gonna have the courage to do
the leap so it's like the courage the
leap of faith
to go like go against the the therapist
guru that you know and going against
him and whatever he was saying and then
ganging up
you know and doing the smear campaign
you know putting my kids against me
and all that stuff that narcissists
actually do
right and i was
you know i felt like spirit carry me
through there was
i didn't have that in me it was
something like
transcendent inside of me some
spiritual superior force that carried me
through that and i had to jump and make
a leap and you know what
it's like i just like i didn't need
spousal support i just wanted to be out
there i just
child he wasn't working actually so if
if i divorce him turn out i would have
to pay him so i had now to figure out
how to support myself
right with no family around you know
housewife
this and that so there's all these
financial things
there's all these things that sometimes
keep people trapped
i had to blow through all that and i had
to jump and make the leap
and no child support no family around
none of that stuff right so i jumped and
then
once i jumped a net was formed and i was
caught
yes right so it does take courage so
many times for me to start my business
for me to invest on you know my business
and you know let go of some other
patterns and you know fear of investment
and how much money is spent on this and
that
i had to make another leap and you know
and
invest on myself and i think i've spent
now
like anywhere from six to a hundred
thousand dollars
in in personal development in coaching
in in growing and learning and continue
and it's
just endless right my next
uh dream is to go do 40 years of zen
it's a 15 000 uh
program in which we know david aspray
from bulletproof bulletproof labs
he has a thing called 40 years of zen
which anthony did
a couple times he's like the world
champion of 40 years of zen
in which you get your brain scanned and
training
the patterns and things that are not
linking up right for performance for
um like neurotransmitters everything
gets
mapped and then you meditate in the in
in these different pods and they have
all kinds of ways of track
just to bring your consciousness and
your mind and your
brain power cognition and all that
including spirituality to the next level
to the next it's all measurable
right so this is 40 years old pinnacle
of neuro and biofeedback the pinnacle of
it
yes so that's coming up that so that's
you know that's something that oh my god
it stick takes a week it takes fifteen
thousand dollars
but if you don't make those leaps you
stay stuck you can't keep doing the same
thing expect different results
so if you really want to be one percent
if you really want to
uh manifest prosperity abundance you
have to
you have to match that vibration right
and you have to take the leap and you
have to do the work
and you have to take the time and you're
gonna say i'm gonna do whatever it takes
and then once you put that energy out
that the universe catches you
the universe cat continues to catch you
and continues to do so
man
that story where you talk about like the
vision
coming of needing to with the
level of the warrior champion
intelligence and emotional quotient
put the sword that's already there
through and put the the relationship
out of its suffering and enable a fresh
start for both of
you man that's a really good way to tell
that story the analogy of like the
swords already there
like in spot of suffering and just to
fully
somebody has to do somebody has to do it
put out of the suffering
go fresh like you know that
like the birth of this new year you know
it's just like the birth of the
the next aspect chapter of your of your
lives
and so i'm glad that you
have that strong analogy for it it's a
really resonant
and and like you said it you know you
you it's it's to have the faith
that in doing so i am going to
on a daily basis continue
pursuing abundance continue pursuing
prosperity manifesting that
and the universe forms the net
as you keep going it forms the pathways
it's constantly rearranging itself
according to your beliefs
as you have that great quote that we
shared across our
stories recently as well
that's the process and it requires
multiple leaps of faith
over and over again more and more
investing into the process of
the fullest self-realization the fullest
self-actualization
and i really like the 40 years of zen's
fascinating it sounds like
a really strong bio-neurofeedback like
what we were describing in terms of the
biometric analysis
of like people in the greatest positions
of power on the planet
we should funnel them into places like
40 years of zen
that would be great to quantify
their states of of existence
and how to up level to
states of more bliss more peace more
non-duality
to where they can potentially impact the
thousands of people that are potentially
employed at their companies
and potentially millions of people that
they touch with their products and
services across the planet
that's a great top-down way we talk
about that a lot
in chapter six of high-level perception
and it seems to be one of the core
methods for our future in order to be
able to
butterfly affect the awakening most
efficiently
is through that method at the same time
as we do the bottom up
through the grassroots through the
through
through people on their own journeys
that are not in those
massive positions of power
i'm really happy that you went through
the process of
sharing with us a very detailed
representation
of how you visually see people evolving
that's a key and if and if we don't do
that
if your viewer or listener
and you haven't undergone a process
of visualizing human development
we highly recommend
if you're only listening
across our audio platforms is to look up
david hawkins levels of consciousness or
you can look up
claire graves spiral dynamics
there's a lot of different world leaders
in the human development
spectrum here that you can
visualize check out that helps a lot
with the visual representations
or come and check out that our actual
video conversation
on youtube where we actually have the
graphics embedded themselves
these are ridiculously powerful and
helpful
and they give us they give us a
framework
yeah to know where we are where we want
to go
and then it's up to us yeah i felt so
lost growing up i
i felt like there was something else
that was better it's almost like a
longing right where does that come from
right like like a knowing that
this can't be right this reality the way
i'm living the way i'm experiencing
where i'm coming from
there's something like more amazing
that i'm missing right where does that
come from
so i think really important is to um
learn about yourself self
knowledge right aristotle i think
said uh no it's like the temple of uh
the delphi i think it says like the
temple of apollo at delphi
at the very top says know thyself it's
the most
famous delphic maxim two words no
no thyself and uh once you
know thyself you get to know the gods
and the universe that's right right so
what does that mean like first you have
to understand
that be be interested in that
right that's that's gotta be your
intention
so in the intentional universe so if
that's your intention that you're
putting out there you want to know
yourself
then then that's the very beginning the
very first steps right
there's so many personality um
i recommend the enneagram the enneagram
test
it's a good one and so is the big five
personality traits is another really
good one it's
currently called uh the world's best
psychometric
analysis which is very interesting but
enneagram is also really good
really good because once you
understand your psychological
mapping let's say the the map of your
psyche and your tendencies and all that
then you have something to work from
knowing your tendencies right before you
fall into a hole you kind of see the
hole coming it's like
oh you know 100 100 miles to
to to the hole right 200 miles there's
like some warning signs because
you've done some work in and and you
know that that
is it's gonna recur right those tests
are gonna happen again if you don't
master them they repeat
so it's really important we know our
patterns all right so you can find out
some personality tests like that
and there's free tests online that you
can do
um and also understanding the nature of
you know i call the in my book i'm
writing a book called
the guide for the warrior champion
mindset guide for success and freedom
i write about the parts the human parts
right
there's we have several parts so we
don't really know much about our own
selves
so first of all we have you know
spiritual intellectual
emotional and physical a lot of people
get the physical and
the intellectual also kind of stuck
there
and now my work with my clients
is emotional because i think that's
really what was big for me
that's what really unlocks like the
mindset is through your emotions
right if you have no access to your
emotions you're stuck
so many people because of abandonment
issues childhood issues
uh programming painful things that we
can't even remember where they are
that's where hypnosis comes in and nlp
comes in you don't remember what event
has wounded you and scarred you for life
but you just kind of
have a limp emotional right and then and
it's painful
so we create a shell around our heart
so we
we try to protect ourselves and then we
can't
in in an effort to not feel pain we
withdraw emotionally from ourselves and
from the world
so that's that's that's very uh
sad uh state of events because most
people
are wounded they're either cynical or
fearful
they can't commit full on to a
relationship they're jaded
one way or another right so transcending
all that getting in touch to them
there's no way around you have to go
through the pain
to get to the to the other side
it's through the pain it's through the
suffering it's true
it's through the dark that you're gonna
find the light you have to
to have that courage right it's the leap
is that courage is that willingness
right is the acceptance right so
it's it's an intentional effort of like
showing up to the mat
showing up to the fight and putting on
the gloves and putting on your belt
and you show up and you know you're
going to be tapped out but you go back
and then you go back again that's the
warrior mindset right
you show up and then you go through that
pain through the pain of lifting weights
of showing up to the gym
of getting up early whatever you have to
take whatever you have to do is whatever
it takes
that's the champion mindset that's the
mindset i want people to understand
you're gonna do whatever it takes to get
there
what else are you gonna do you're gonna
live in suffering you're going to live
in scarcity is scarcity you're going to
live
in in in victim mindset no you're going
to rise up and sometimes through
physical
right through physical exercise and gym
and and getting in shape
that's how you start to to to to create
uh a framework for you to pivot from
to go through the emotional maybe it's
too big of a leap right
so you go through the physical we need
to develop our emotional
our intellect always learning and
studying
things that actually adding uh to your
consciousness
not just trivia and like um
you know you have to filter what you
what you consume
intellectually because it's your it's
your
it's your gait to your consciousness so
we have to filter
right and then sourcing out good
nutrition for your intellect and that's
how you
also grow and access your spirituality
right so you have to access all these
different levels so all these are there
are different parts
physical emotional intellectual
spiritual i have an acronym can can we
draw
more so let's draw do you want me to or
do you want to you can so
draw a pie like a circle it's gonna be a
pie that has
three um oh concentric circles
like a pie that has three pieces oh well
three pieces okay to the pie okay
yeah it's like a pizza with three pieces
equal like a peace
but it's not necessary it can be yeah
yeah yeah yeah and then
a bigger circle all around on the outer
that's the spiritual
okay beautiful right it touches
everything all the aspects
i'm going to use a different color for
it i learn and
derive some of this this is like my own
representation of it and my acronym and
all that but i derived this from
bob hoffman from the huffman process
work
in which we really learn and work with
our parts
and then there's a parts integration
exercise which i love which was from nlp
that's how i fell in love with nlp
yes neuro-linguistic programming is when
you
integrate all these parts that they work
together so much of our work is to
integrate the
spirit with the material yes right the
physical
of course and integrate the the
psychological and spiritual work and
just
integrate integrate integra yes yes
so so the acronym is spice p is for
physical
inside the orange right so or where do
you like to write it
yeah p would be one of the slices the
slices
and okay and so p okay
cool p for physical can i write physical
as well small
okay physical
and then i is intellectual or intellect
i call it intellectual or intellectual
part
[Music]
or intellect and then e
is emotional
and on the outer side the big circle is
spiritual and where do you usually write
that like here at the top something can
be
anywhere you want
i have a video uh that i go through in
detail with each of these on my youtube
channel as well it's all about the pies
so the acronym is price p e p
i e s and you can find uh adelita's
youtube uh channel link in the bio below
as well she has videos on these topics
so pies p physical
i intellectual e emotional
pi but then the s is the spiritual
the encompassing of it all it's really
beautiful
i love it we've had we've had many of
these um
like um kind of like visual
representations
of maximizing potential and
becoming more harmonic and imbalanced in
this type of stuff
and i like yours a lot it's very simple
it's very important i also like how um
it's a good synthesis with many of the
other ones like we had
michael holt on the program and josh
holland on the program who we were
hanging out with at anthony's
and theirs both
start with awareness there's both start
with consciousness
as like the most primal thing and that
helps everything else downstream with
your
nutrition exercise sleep
goals information like you indicated as
well
super important that gatekeeper of what
you intake you want to
unsubscribe from things that don't serve
you anymore
and people and places people and places
and information
yeah all of that and yeah i like this a
lot so then this is going to be
um kind of the core this is like the
core
thesis of your upcoming book
yeah it's it's the beginning is like the
initial uh
introduction because you have to know
thyself you have to know your parts
and uh to be able to start developing
each one of them
and it's a constant work that you're
always working on in your physical
it's your nutrition it's your exercise
it's your hydration you know dr david
hawkins said that
a lot of his patients that were uh
they were diagnosed with you know heavy
like schizophrenia
or like really uh that's what he dealt
with on a day-to-day like
serious uh psycho pathological uh
psychosis and things like that so
he said that just by giving them
maybe a couple of supplements maybe like
magnesium
and vitamin d and
hydration and just regulating the blood
like blood like the blood levels
that that would stabilize them to almost
have almost
no um uh
how do you say like outbursts right of
like
of erratic behaviors and things like
that
so i i see that with my clients it's
like i work a lot with people that have
anxiety
and depression so they come to me
and it's and sometimes it's like
okay so what is your nutrition like and
then they're eating all processed foods
yeah exactly and they have no exercise
and then we're forced into the computer
all day or not having a job or
sitting or sitting and like you know
feeling
having a mask on and all this stuff so
independent of what's going on in the
world if you're just eating
terrible food all processed food that's
pretty much
poison like you're creating inflammation
you're creating leaky gut and that's
gonna the gut
um uh gut
uh brain uh connection it's gonna
it's gonna make you crazy basically
right
so you're not to be able to regulate
your emotions because
the body and mind is connected and there
are so many
uh receptors and sensitivities in in
your gut
as much as in your brain so in your
heart so
those things are all connected so you
have to always
really mind your nutrition the physical
thing is really primarily
primarily primarily when looking at
all this stuff right so if if you
if you want to regulate your emotions
make sure that you're exercising that
you're drinking enough water
and that you're not eating a bunch of
sugar and that's the very beginning
yep right because it feels like anxiety
yeah so
um spot on so so there's clients that
sometimes have fear of fly
flying right and then you're gonna go
examine is that the day that they fly
they eat
all wrong like you don't sleep well at
night because you're kind of
packing and timing and this and that and
you don't eat and your blood levels all
messed up so
turns out they don't have fear flying
they have anxiety but their blood levels
is all messed up so hey let's
regulate that and guess what you know
you um you don't even need anything like
the hypnosis and all that stuff is just
like hey you just need help you just
need some insight
yeah that's all sometimes that's all it
takes and that's the whole hippocrates
let thy food be thy medicine let thy
medicine be thy food and that's the
whole
ayurvedic tradition as well of the
of the entire sort of indian
style of understanding that the actual
intake of food is energetic
itself and so we can't go off eating
um at the most physical portion of the
pie
that you illustrate physical
you gotta not just intake refined sugars
and processed
meats and foods and
undergo stressful habits with parents
smoking pack a day
like complete lack of of vitamin d
no sunlight
no movement of the body hunched over a
computer
eight straight hours cortisol levels
from
from from deadlines and from and from
angry and not compassionate
people around you
disastrous absolutely disastrous and
most
first principled like you indicate it's
the most
first principled is that that physical
and you're right that to filter that
first is paramount and
i love all of the
you know this really deeply reminds me
also of
in that first part of
of chapter six on the ai coach
before that biometrics of awakening we
talk about
this ai coach in this data visualization
of our self of our unique individuation
and it also
it really resonates with what you were
saying
a little bit ago
which is something along the lines of
this which is that
as your first intention that you must
set which is know thyself
awaken self realize the one infinite
creator as your first intention
know your self realization and self
actualization
the integration and the
unique individuation and as your second
thing which is super interesting that
you brought this up
because it's basically what
i illustrate here which is that you want
to
visualize your data in this case your
psychometrics that's why you know edward
tufte says above
all else show the data and so
if you have a a clear visual of your
psychometrics like your big five
your personality traits ocean is the
acronym
openness extraversion agreeableness
sorry openness conscientiousness is the
c
then e is extraversion a is
agreeableness and
n is neuroticism so i miss that c
and so that sort of
psychometric understanding as a baby
step towards know thyself is a really
good one
it's a really good one it's usually the
first one that i also recommend
people but you'd be surprised that even
how many people
won't even take that first step actually
the numbers were
if this is right i mean claire graves
don bett chris cowan gave
i think an approximate similar answer
that david hawkins gave which is
approximately
eight and a half out of every 10 people
approximately 85
of people are living in some sort of a
more egoic
level of consciousness have in a sense
uh i haven't undergone even a
a maybe a uh a transpersonal
state of of existence which is like
when you at least begin slowly
uh revealing the
appealing off the layers to your to your
onion to your to your soul
and and getting at this most primal
level of consciousness
and then that at least
opens you up to some of the more uh
deeper levels but so these little ai
coaches are really helpful because they
do things like
slowly like nudge us if we can visualize
our data
towards these more enlightened states
and that these are really important
especially for people
in positions of power so that was
something i wanted to bring up and then
another thing that i
thought would be interesting is it might
be good potentially for
you to highlight because we've had
a good chunk of the conversation has
been
um super fascinating unpacking this
at a like a really uh embodied
level of the development of
consciousness and the different
strategies to do so
um i would like to maybe have you share
examples of the actual like kind of
nitty gritty examples of
maybe with me with if you want to do
nlp if you want to do hypnosis if you
want to do
a meditation or mindfulness experience
if you um
want to show us something in jiu jitsu
if you want to do any of those
all of the above let's do it let's do it
well um just before we go there into a
more uh practical
uh side of things i would just conclude
the parts
um yes know your parts right so there's
another
set of parts which is the essence and
the ego
i call it so that's sometimes confusing
because
people you know sometimes if you
study psychology the ego and the id and
the freud work kind of has different
um definitions the terminology is a
little bit different
but young you would say maybe
the shadow side like your shadow work
things like that of that nature that
would be your ego and your essence is
who you truly are
so those two parts are very important
to know and to be very familiar
uh with them so your essence
is who you you are who you were
who you're always gonna be is your is
your higher self
right compared to your lower self
your ego is it's kind of like an
interface that allows you to
function in this in this
um plane of consciousness in this
in this reality that we're living in
right now
and but it's something that you can't
let the ego take over right you have to
identify yourself with your essence
and disassociate from your ego and just
kind of keep an
eye on your ego and to always understand
the nature of the ego so that you're not
falling into egoic patterns because
they're destructive
right the ego is destructive the ego i
wrote the ego is i read that somewhere
but i post that on my instagram
my instagram at adelita live we'll pull
that up
i it's one of the there it is the ego
it's right there right in the heart and
center exactly
exactly the ego is not your amigo
it's not your amigo boom right so
when you understand the ego and the
patterns that come in
it can destroy your relationship it can
destroy
um uh everything that you try to do
so when you understand that
you can disassociate from it and then
when you see
egoic things coming up you can now
have a choice and respond instead of
react
right so not to let your ego
um take control
and and then i have a list of different
attributes of the ego the ego
always wants to be right the ego already
knows everything
like like the reality is that we don't
know anything
right always have a open mind to
to think that maybe perhaps your point
of view could be wrong
like only the madman is absolutely
certain of things right was that robert
anton wilson yeah yeah i love that guy
so i mean when you when you really
try to be right and then you think that
only your
you know your religion is right and
you're intolerant
and you're getting offended everything
is offended and you're taking
sides and it's this or that you know
you're in egoic
patterns and that is destructive
and at the end of the day if you just
let that run your life you're gonna end
up
alone broke and sad and unhealthy
and that's where the ego wants to kill
you so just
watch out for that and then try to find
out what your essence is
and work on developing and getting
acquainted with that
and falling in love with that that's who
you really are
exactly i love that yeah ego essence i
love that lower higher self yeah
well well said and again that follows
that that
human development that we were talking
about totally
yeah so what do we want to do so
hypnosis uh
i would like to talk about hypnosis a
little bit so hypnosis
is something that we go in and out of
hypnosis every day
some people are afraid of hypnosis but
they don't know that they're being
hypnotized
every day on a daily basis whether you
know it or not there's lots of
propaganda yeah
propaganda and also from the time just
how we're born how we're designed from
the time that we are born from the time
we're seven
we are in a very suggestible state so
the first seven years of your life
whatever you tell a kid it's gonna
imprint
directly into their unconscious mind so
there's a conscious mind and
conscious mind so the conscious mind is
only um
five to eight percent of the capacity of
your whole mind
okay mind is different than the brain
right the mind is more
subjective it's maybe an energy field
right it's
it's not your brain
itself it includes that your neurology
and
much more right so the
mind uh the unconscious mind it's like
95 of your of your power of your mind
so when you wanna create your reality
you creating from the unconscious mind
but when you when you are being
programmed as a child
or every time before you go to sleep 30
minutes before and as soon as you wake
up that 30
first 30 minutes as soon as you wake up
whatever
uh happens during those times is who
you become unconsciously that becomes
your unconscious patterns
those are the unconscious pattern
patterns of your parents
and of your great grandparents and
grandparents and everybody
so we are carrying this
egoic patterns unconscious patterns that
we we swear that we're not going to be
like our parents but
we grow up and then we're doing the
exact same thing
right so we have to
reprogram we have to uh
remember who we are then we have to
um reprogram our mind
right reprogram our mind and recreating
our reality
so first of all we have to remember who
we are
our divine essence once we know and
remember who we are we know we can
recreate our reality
recreating a reality by reprogramming
our unconscious mind our unconscious
mind is polluted
it's filled with all kinds of
uh wrong information like virus let's
say
like so if if you like uh computer
analogies
you know love these yeah i love these so
your mind you have to reprogram there's
viruses
and um we're gonna have to go in
and remove those to be able to install
new software okay so we're going to
install new software
which is the reprogramming and then
recreating
does that make sense i love i'm taking
so many notes yeah
so in hypnosis that's what we do so
we we live in a state of hypnosis
because
when you study how to become a hypnotist
what you do and it's you create an
overload of units
uh mental units so that people get
overloaded
the conscious mind and it just kind of
gives up
and overwhelmed and then you can access
a path through the unconscious mind
so if you go to a place where people are
talking blah blah blah blah blah or if
you're watching tv
and and if you're not in your if you're
not connected to your breath
you're being brainwashed you're being
hypnotized every time you
a lot of information you start to get
that glare in your eye you're gonna get
tired and it's like you're open you're
in hypnotic state
so it's not something you have to fear
but it's something that happens
you know when you're a child most
pronounced but every single day we get
in and out of hypnosis several times the
more stress you have
the more you're living in your um
sympathetic
you know fight or flight
mechanism that means you are prone
and you're subject to hypnosis so the
events that are happening in the world
economic all this are political you name
it
right those are creating overwhelming
units of stress and anxiety so you're
highly hypnotizable
so whatever you're consuming is going
deep in your programming
so we need to be really careful with
that and then people sometimes are
afraid to go to a hypnotist
or a hypnotherapist because they they
don't know what hypnosis is they feel
like
you know they're scared of what you know
you never lose
um consciousness in hypnosis
right hypno comes from sleep but you
don't actually fall asleep
okay so you're just kind of getting to a
relaxed focused
state in which you can access the
unconscious mind
and go in there and reprogram so i would
talk to you like if you're my client i
would say
what is the goal that you have what is
something that you want to what it is
that you
want instead of what you don't want
right because people come saying i don't
want this i don't like this my marriage
my job and my
this and that's like what do you want
because the universe only in the
unconscious mind is going to understand
what you want
so tell me what is something that you
would like
to get out of this mini session today
wow another just interesting thing that
came while you were sharing was that
before i just give my answer that sir
the
stressed state that's more hypnotic
hypnotizable that one is the
exact kind of lower levels that we've
been talking about
and then the higher levels that we've
been talking about
are very much relaxed
and like in many of the perennial mystic
traditions
what is said are things like in zulchen
we talk about the lions gaze
and that's like the relaxed lion on the
savannah
that is literally melted into the
oneness that oceanicness
and like that holding that frequency of
being
is a completely different it's like
you're a complete
sovereign
of the breath life force conscious
of everything that is happening around
you
in a very deeply relaxed level versus
when you're like
super stressed super fight or flight
super sympathetic
we're really much more programmable
we're much more in those states you can
tell how
programmable you are because of how
easily you're triggered
because like when something happens and
you get triggered right away by it
versus when you're in that relaxed state
you are the observer
first and foremost you are that infinite
observation
and so when it happens you're just in a
state of relaxation
and then you on what unfolds through the
vessel
unfolds intuitively and so
wow i i had to hit that ball back
because you you hit it so well over i
had to hit it
oh that's amazing that's the flow state
right that's uh
that's what you're trying to channel
like in your fights in your life you
know
you know everything that you do is to be
able to live in cause and not at effect
right i love that i love that
that's what we want to cultivate to live
in a state of dissociation we want to
dissociate from
from the world from the chaos right and
be this observer
so that's such an interesting practice
that you can start to develop through
your breath
right and just observe the world you
don't have to pick and have an opinion
about everything
you don't have to get offended you don't
have to get immersed into the fight
in a way how about you can you know you
know maybe
laugh at it because it's it's it's
humorous if it wasn't so tragic
yeah yeah what would it require
for the
85 percent of people we've been talking
about to have
a moment of laughter about the state of
our
creation a moment of even
hypothesize for one moment could
everything in creation
be absolutely perfect well what happens
is
it's like interface like this so it's
there's no space there's no space
there's no pause yeah
right it's like oh yeah it's so it's
it's
true that's what it was like and for me
too i just want to say because
i was in the same position that you've
been describing through the show
many of the people that come on the show
are in the same position that we
were in years ago where it was just like
that
and now we've gotten here and now we try
and share this
with others and i love i love that
aspect to this
okay so the intention that i'm setting
for we have a hypnosis session that's
occurring so whenever
a mini run right a mini run yeah a mini
hypnosis session
so so an intention
um now can i make the intention
self-realization whatever you want
i would love for that to be the
intention yeah okay
yeah okay so we're gonna play a little
bit
called cling language have you ever do
that clean language
whoa is this nlp stuff too it's
uh it's it's own technique
forgot judy something it's related clean
language
clean language so it's like a game okay
it's like i'm looking for metaphors
for metaphors metaphors so okay so if
you were to be self-realized
yes i'm looking for keywords ocean
okay and to be in
self-realize in emotion what what would
that be like
melting oh man you've done this before
i'm just giving you what comes up oh my
god you're like
so on top of it you just so got it
so ocean and immersed immersion
what else melting melting melting
into the ocean right that would be
um feel like self-realization
and then when you when you're melting in
the ocean
self-realized
in that immensity right
what would that be like
bliss peace
and peace okay so now we're chunking up
chunking up
in nlp we're just going higher and
higher right
in in definition in the broad into the
broadness
of it all so then if you're immersed
in this vastness of the ocean and you're
melting
into this vastness and in
self-realization
and bliss right
yes in belize what would that be like
ecstasy feel like ecstasy
okay okay so got some keywords to work
with
so we can come back that was not the
hypnotic part that was just a
conversational
um cognitive almost part of it it's like
a more advanced cognitive but you can
come with like almost start and go there
right it's a pre-hypnotic like you can
kind of if you
if you people that meditate can go there
like
you're already going come back yeah
come back with me if
you noticed what what adelita was doing
throughout that was she was very
intelligently very spiritually acting as
a
very well-versed catalyst
for my process in this case
so her essence was
uplifting the intention it was mirroring
the intention it was repeating the words
that i was
choosing with my intentions to elevate
yes yes and the unconscious mind works
with metaphors that's the language of
the mind
if you just tell stories you're
hypnotizing somebody
that's what milton erickson did that's
an ericksonian hypnosis
technique which is he didn't do anything
people walked up to him he came he
talked to jokes told stories they left
they didn't have a problem
he didn't do anything oh but i'm cured
oh
interesting now so language
it's really important the words
that we are are being said and uh
and the stories that we hear the things
we subscribe to
the movies that we watch we're being
led one way or the other yeah okay
always yes
so yeah the robert anton wilson also
said that you know
hypnosis is something that all
politicians world leaders
various they all know about the nature
hypnosis they know and they
use it and the process is like
for us to be de-hypnotized so i
de-hypnotize people very often
yeah right we're all walking in in a
trance of disempowerment
so so we have to to remember
the same way there's like a mantra in
transcendental meditation
is the same way there's a mantra coming
from politicians
it's super interesting you can see
it the mantra you can see the mantra
coming from the most
self dealing corporations that are
trying to just
put high fructose corn syrup into your
veins they have their mantras that they
pitch
hypnotically okay so that was the first
part
that was just initial that's looking
like a part of a little bit of a
cognitive like what your goals are
and then we're expanding upon your goals
okay so now we're gonna do a little bit
of
induction in a little bit of a some
funny game so
i want you to bring your your arms out
like this okay
your hands like in front of you
yes yes okay like this
maybe elevate it a little bit like at
eye level like this
right and interlace your fingers okay
and then i want you to
squeeze everything really tight like oh
sure sure
in your wrist and then bring your
forearms together
right and then it's like it's a strong
situation and in a moment not just yet
keep pressing it really hard we're gonna
open up our index fingers like this not
just yet look at me
open up your index finger like this not
just the end
but squeeze everything tight and when
you do i want you to look right
in between them and notice an
electromagnetic force go ahead and open
look between your fingers no inlet
electromagnetic force
pulling them together look in the middle
of your fingers
put all your attention your focus and
notice how they want to come together
come
together closer and closer with each and
every breath and touch
touch now go ahead and close your eyes
and let
go of your arms take a deep breath so
that was the working of your unconscious
mind right
and then now for another exercise coming
back
open your eyes look at me only focus on
the sound of my voice
open your eyes bring your hand right in
front of you like this
so i want you to focus on the very top
of your middle finger with all your
intention and all your attention
which every ounce of your energy
elevated a little bit higher and a
little bit closer to your face
and breathe and notice how your hand
tends to come in magnetically attracted
closer and closer just like the fingers
with each and every breath closer and
closer
closer and closer the more you breathe
the more you allow
the closer it becomes all by itself
allowing permitting allowing your
unconscious mind the intelligence of
your own
mind to move your hand all the way and
touch your face
at any point reaching skin contact
and deep sleep deep sleep
each and every time i suggest the word
deep sleep to you atlas
for the purpose of hypnosis with my
permission
with your permission rather you will
reach this
depth of hypnosis or even deeper and the
physical body will completely relax
each and every time i suggest the word
deep sleep
the physical body will completely relax
so you can access the non-conscious part
of your mind
the part of your mind
that's most powerful
in the part of your mind in which all
your goals and your dreams
reside your power your intention
so with each and every breath we're
gonna go deeper
and i want you to imagine the very top
of a staircase
with each and every breath
on the very top of a staircase that is
ten steps
long ten steps long
of your own design it is beautiful
powerfully built handrails
when we we get into the hypnotic states
our mouth tends to be dry
and you start to notice a little dryness
around your eyes also flutter
right so if you notice those tendencies
go ahead and nod your head yes
and going down this magnificent
celestial staircase we're going to start
with your right foot first
we're going to go down 10 steps deep
with your right first
first going down now ten
left nine going down eight
seven six
five four
three two
one deep sleep deep sleep
going even deeper each and every time i
suggest the word deep sleep to you the
purpose of hypnosis
physical body will completely relax
completely relax now imagine a waterfall
of light
and divinity and beauty and bliss
like an ocean like a waterfall
like vast and immense just washing
pouring down over you at the very bottom
of your own staircase
and it's immensity right there it is
the immensity of the beauty
of the bliss
of melting
of the magnificence of it all
allowing yourself to go deeper and
experience
through your eyes see through your own
ear
hear through your own ears see you
through yours make it big
make it bright really feel it in your
heart and allow that to expand a sense
of joy and gratitude and oneness
and bliss like the ocean
like melting like
enlightenment
and remember remembering who you are
remembering where you came from
remember you can always access the
states remember
it's always there for you this emotional
state this
place in your unconscious mind
it's always there and it's growing
it's growing as you allow it to feel it
even deeper
and allow to merge
with the oneness with yourself and the
beauty of the vastness
of the ocean the universe
just rewiring your brain
your neurology your physicality your
emotions
with this knowing
with this level of understanding
of unconditional love
right breathe that in and let that grow
and expand in allowing these
changings this knowing to continue
throughout the next
few days and weeks ahead integrating
deeply
into your neurology rewiring
yourself creating more space for more
opportunities for more beauty for more
joy prosperity and abundance in your
life
with a deep sense of gratitude we're
gonna come
up and out of the state of hypnosis
i'm gonna count from one through five
sealing the door of the subconscious
from any negative
influence and keeping all the positive
knowing in lessons that we've learned
allow that to permeate your life from
now into the future
with the one coming up and now to two
more alert three more awake four with
the deep sense of joy and gratitude
and with five is eyes open wide awake
one two three four five eyes open wide
awake right away
welcome back
how many minutes do you think that was
because time is relative
right that's when you know that time can
be compressed or stretched in hypnosis
if i were to tell you that was an hour
that would be a long show right seven
minutes
seven minutes that's pretty accurate i
mean i don't think yeah
it wasn't super long but and it felt
so good visualizing
the re-baselining like what we're
talking about throughout the show
because when we talk about your
ability to visually guide the intention
of the agent that is setting the
intention
and to walk them through that process of
making some sort of like a physical like
engaging process for them to hone in
on and then for it to have that sort of
more suggestive faculties
open up and for them to
have their gatekeeper move to the side
and then for you to access and for that
intention to really
be beautifully set
and actualized through your storytelling
abilities is really great because that
visualization of the love and the light
the visualization of the waterfall of
the serenity the visualization of that
beautiful infinite scene put me into the
position
of being in that child like infinite
awareness
and just being there for that
you know extended period of time
being there being present with it
visualizing the process of
as we're closing out the scene that
we're you know we're shutting that door
to all of the negative
forces that could potentially come in
and try and flood and pervert that
scenario
and so there's a lot of sort of
it's important to is very beautiful
your skillfulness in that process and
also the importance of people to become
more
willing to undergo hypnotic processes
that
serve their intention rather than to
have the hypnosis propagandized
from the exterior in self-dealing
habits towards um those egoic
interests to just drain the energy from
individuals so it was really good it's
really solid
rocky nice how did how did it resonate
with you how did you feel about it
i felt like your feet were moving right
so that's when you realized the stairs
right
i got so excited about the stairs yeah
and you were so
deep in hypnosis that you didn't even do
what we call progressive relaxation
which we kind of go in and we kind of
relax
the you know the the feet and the toes
and the muscles and the leg
and then this and that we didn't even go
through that do i have a journey
sometimes it's
it's a it's it's a it's a
ball of light that healing bulb like the
scans your whole body emotionally
spiritually
there's a whole new thing that and that
was not even needed
because you're already there so um
usually we do
like some inductions we do some tests
some arm raising and then
we do what we call progressive
relaxation relax all the muscles
and then get into a space of like going
deeper
do a staircase and then after the
staircase we start to
add in did you see how i add in those
keywords right the keywords before you
knew they're all there
right the bliss the melting
so it's not what i want for you totally
it's the words that you
you're mirroring right that you have
already
the metaphors that work for you not
what i want so exactly get my ego out of
the way
and let you just facilitate a space for
you to
there's no such thing as hypnosis we say
all hypnosis
is self-hypnosis yeah self-hypnosis yeah
yeah so
and that's why um when joe dispenza says
you are the placebo
right you pretty much just need
that that letting yourself
do the process get out of your own
[ __ ] way
yes in so many ways the conscious mind
the inner chatter right so if you can
calm that down
right the more you practice you can calm
that down and that's what i do before
jiu jitsu matches i hypnotized myself
there you go
exactly likewise before my tedx talk
before you saw
before the show i do that with every
guest before the show
we just go into a very inward process
and during that process i'm just
i'm just manifesting the absolute
highest for the conversation
that's my intention in that process
and so that can be thought of as
intention as
self-reflection as container
as hypnosis self-hypnosis
container hypnosis container intention
it's like
let it you know manifest it know what
you want let it happen know what you
want
yeah yeah and and hold that thought
right don't let your thought wonder like
know what you want
believe that you can have it and then
take action
adelita is on absolute fire i love it
i love it this has been such a good
conversation
i want to ask a two
two last thoughts um the first one
is a question about what
you think what you feel
the godhead of our reality is
so what do you think is the attractor
that our complex system of a
civilization is evolving towards
what is our telos what is that
purpose what is that attractor what are
we what's the end
state and does that
continue a cyclic process of exploring
more
how do you see that happening what do
you see there
well there's like different things
happening at different levels
so there's the individual level and then
there's the collective
uh conscious unconscious most of the
time
making the unconscious conscious right
so i think that's part of the
process for us and uh once we become
conscious become self-aware right we
become more intentional we create our
reality we transcend all that we
transcend
the um
the need the want the pain the suffering
right and we achieve
a state of like instant manifestation of
no
pain of like
just absolute power
of of of being
in in oneness right in oneness with the
universe and
with the natural laws and with god we
will you align with the will of god
and the creator the universe so you're
living
that reality of being in service
of the ultimate um
uh life force generator
and and with a deep sense of
empathy and compassion and understanding
once you realize that all you want to do
is help and to serve
and you become one because
ultimately that's who we are we are
a spark of divinity so we just
realize that like deeply like we
live that right reality so right now we
can just
only imagine so there are different
processes you can do to go there and
back
but then we were faced with the with the
traffic and the freeways and the
in taxes and the media
let me be even more specific because
your answer is very aligned with my
answer
in many ways but i think that what we
both align on there is a step
beyond where we're at now but i want to
see what you think
and feel is beyond that step so
in my understanding this would be a
hypothesis and it'd be interesting to
hear what you think about this
there's this word it's called the
metaverse and it basically means it's a
synthesis of artificial general
intelligence
bio and neurotechnology and
indistinguishable virtual realities
okay you put all those things together
into one thing you call it the metaverse
let's say in the next couple of decades
maybe in 50 or 100 years
we're building these indistinguishable
virtual realities
and we're using technologies like
neurolink and artificial general
intelligence
and extremely high power capacities in
order to
immerse ourselves in these
indistinguishable virtual worlds
and just browse states of qualia
a phenomenology of consciousness and
just
go between worlds just like we do with
our video game console today
we jump between different games that we
play
we say files we exit games we jump back
in we level up characters
so my question to you would be if that's
where we're heading
if that sounds like something that it
makes sense that that's where we're
heading
is that also not what this already is
right
right okay and is that then the cyclic
cosmology is that then the cyclic
exploration
that we're undergoing of all of the
different states of experience that are
possible
we're eternally going to explore all of
the different reality designs
and all of the different states of
consciousness of awareness of sentience
that exists
where we continuously realize as i said
with wahad
al-wujud the unity of all unveiling and
finding so across all these different
realities
there is sentience that is unveiling
and finding out that it is that one
infinite creator
wow i think in some level that's already
what's
happening i'm not sure about the
artificial intelligence and all that
because
and do i understand planet earth is not
all there is
there are many other civilizations in
other beings out there that would be
uh too much empty space i think for the
creator
that he likes a really big
empty space you know imagine if you had
i you know you just put one little dot
in a huge
uh white sheet of paper that is like the
size of
like a building it's just a tiny little
dot and that's not even like
you know a good representation because
it's infinitely much
bigger than that uh you know so
there's other um many counts of other uh
beings of their interactions and they
are living
way more advanced than us so if we are
toying with artificial intelligence i
think that they are like
have gone there and beyond and
so if it depends on the level of
consciousness and
and morality in spiritual development of
the civilization some civilizations
could you know like ours
not very morally evolved but very
technologically
advanced you know by now then what
happens is
it's it's dangerous right scary it's
dangerous like don't do it because
you're
sub 200 don't mess with that stuff like
you you belong
in a in a
in a place where you're doing personal
development and like
self work and and not necessarily
redesigning uh human consciousness when
you haven't even achieved
a a higher level so in other places
of the planet in which maybe they're
more morally advanced i think yeah it's
a good thing but for us i think it's
just dangerous
because we're not there yet so the point
of it all
and we may get there and then we may do
the exact process
that we talk about and then that may be
exactly where we came from
it's really exciting exactly it's really
exciting but we're always learning
and picking something up right i think
we're always in the process of
learning yes the character the video
game character
continues across lifetimes here
across different soul vehicles in
different realities
and it becomes potentially more and more
exciting and difficult and taking on
like joseph and the code of many colors
taking on
many different embodiments
of the one infinite creator realizing
itself and that's so profound that's
like the coolest game
that exists i don't know if i can even
think of a cooler game
that could exist then literally
one infinite creator unveiling
and finding itself across different
vehicles of
sentience in different realities like
what
this is the best game in town
that's so dope yeah it's a lot about
evolving and the evolution and learning
and growth
and expansion of your awareness
and unconditional love i think eternally
that's right i think that continues to
expand
spot on yep i love it
last funny question silly question we
have on the show what is your favorite
food
my favorite food i've been eating a lot
of protein powder lately
i think that's my favorite food i'm uh
i've been eating um
i tried to eat about 100
100 something grams of protein a day
so i drink protein powder with water
like you know three four times a day
and i really look forward to doing that
i really enjoy it
of course that's your answer when when
you
choose your protein powder
that you think is most optimal what do
you choose
well i choose buy optimizers because oh
shout out shout out bio optimizers
anthony flores
what's wade's last name wade lightheart
lightheart wade lightheart
internet matt gallant and matt gallant
panama city yeah they're meeting right
now as we speak but um
they are protein they're really famous
for enzymes
and they just came out with a line of
nootropics that is customizable
so it's custom-made nootropics
subscription that they have going insane
so you can be like hyper-focused and
like
that's what you know people really at
high levels are doing
to achieve hyper-focused nootropics yeah
so literally i'm combining maybe
you know a couple milligrams of caffeine
with a couple milligrams of
of maybe cbd right stuff like this yeah
no caffeine is higher levels
if you have a pretty high level caffeine
yeah genius chemist that it's it's
really customizable
so it's whatever who you are so they run
tests and things like that
so so that's exciting so they're doing
that they just
came out and just coming out with the
protein powder they're gonna have
uh i think chocolate coming out and then
berry
so are you currently using their
existing protein powder as well
well it hasn't come out yet
yeah no it's coming out when bio
optimizers we'll get a weight and we'll
get weight on the show anthony's been on
the show
matt maybe we'll get also on the program
and uh we'll
shout out more about we'll maybe undergo
the process of
unpacking the nootropics and unpacking
the um the
protein powder and we'll share that with
our audience could be fun could be some
good stuff
that'll be amazing of course you're
doing a hundred grams of protein a day
look at your muscle she's got more
muscle than i do
i've got way more muscle than i do it's
crazy flex
will you flex for us i'm not very strong
right now look at that
that's a rock that's a rock though
that's a rock look at her
they're way more like look at the just
like how
carved they are it's crazy it's nuts
she's like i'm not even lifting
i'm just yeah so should we show like one
jiu jitsu technique first to finalize i
already have time for that yes
okay great okay so i'm going to describe
first because we have to stand up
okay what i like to do is like in jiu
jitsu we start standing but most
jiu-jitsu schools they start sparring on
their knees because
injuries and this and that so it's
really weird and there's this whole
thing of pulling guard which is not cool
which is just kind of like sitting on
your butt
pretty much instead of like taking down
and
engaging like in in in judo or
or wrestling or a leg take down or a
throw or something like that
so i come from like a line like of
wrestling and wrestlers act like i i
became a wrestler here
like in in the us so i
um i don't like pulling guard so
i encourage people because when you
compete you start standing you don't
start on your knees
okay and pulling guard is just grabbing
somebody's hand and sitting on your butt
and then just fighting from the
from there oh i see and i think a more
like
interesting you know more aggressive
more you know you're when you're kidding
a spartan thing to do just
reaching at their face and at their body
from standing up yeah yeah
and maybe tackling but yeah pulling
guard is when you
pull them down and kind of go yeah you
just kind of sit on your butt you just
you just have to touch them you can just
sit on your butt let's say the rest is
fight yeah and then you just kind of
grab their sleeve and sit on your butt
so that's pulling guard
and then they have to engage that and
that in
in ufc they don't even allow that they
make you stand up because nobody likes
to watch that so i think
a more interesting visually interesting
engaging theme maybe a more spartan
thing to do would be to
you know do a takedown or that's my bias
you know some people are like amazing at
pulling arts
okay so just one thing to keep in mind
is that we need the mic so yeah
yeah so how do we wanna so so what i'm
gonna explain
is a it's a throw it's it's kind of like
a throw
but you're not actually hip throw you
don't have to hip throw which is kind of
cool
we get a underhook on each arm we're
going to get an underhook and then we're
going to go around the head
so it's a head and arm sort of throw but
it's kind of like
one that you just twist and sit on your
butt
so right away uh you get
two points for the takedown in a
tournament
and then from there there is a pretty
sweet head and arm triangle that's
already locked in for you to go so it
could be a quick
like throw and submission
and there's also um i've done like a
wrist lock from there because you know
they're already
they're falling they're already locked
so i'm just gonna show right now so
we're gonna get an underhook
and then in each arm on whatever
whichever arm you prefer and then you
lock
a grip like this around the neck
and then you just kind of twist you just
start starting to turn
and then eventually you sit on your butt
and then they will fall with you yeah
yeah yeah right
it's just correct yeah it's just how it
goes if you had a head and an arm you
have them
so that's why in wrestling we um work
the underhooks yes and constantly
swimming under
and doing this game because you don't
want people getting under hook if the if
if they get an underhook hook and then
you come up
yeah and they pull me down i'm yeah you
you can't really defend it it's past
your defense you can't
get from yeah and if you get an
underhook
also opens up the the side of the body
that you can attack that leg
this becomes vulnerable vulnerable yeah
so underhooks are
golden right so we're gonna get an
underhook we're gonna go
gable grip around the neck and we're
gonna twist and then we're gonna sit so
i'm just kinda
i don't know i can't really fall here
but i can show the
lock the the grip okay or we could
um move both chairs
out of the way oh my god and then we
could um just show the visual
okay um because the audio will be too
far away from the mics
right so that's why i already explained
everything we're gonna do okay underhook
lock the gable grip around the neck and
then you just twist and a person was
gonna fall eventually it's just what
happens
okay you could you could add your hip if
you feel you know yeah
after you got this down you could hit
don't throw don't throw me down
but not today yeah okay all right should
we move the chairs and do it okay let's
do it okay all right here we go
i zoomed out the camera for us
okay this is fun all right let's see
this is what this is what our shot looks
like now
okay okay so my head's cut off a little
bit
it is cut off a little bit yeah i can
angle the camera up a little
it'll probably help
okay like this right yes okay
all right all right so oh gosh
we shake hands yeah and then we go right
so what i like to do right off the bat
go slowly just like sure i like to just
do a little bit of a setup which
which is like i would shake you down
like this when you're while you're
thinking about that it's a distraction
right
okay like think about that and then i'm
going here and that's the under hook
right so that's how i get the under hood
set up so let's
condition okay so we're gonna
do a little uh jerky now here and then
we get the underhook once we have this
you just go around here oh [ __ ] and then
now i'm just kind of like turning
turning turning turning turning turning
and it's going down eventually right
yeah
and i'm gonna sit here yep and then
pretty much i have already
locked on the head in the heart and then
am i trying to am i trying to go like
this
right well in jiu jitsu you don't you
don't punch
but um but even if your head is too
close
it's too close it would not really hurt
because it's closed right i want to be
close
if i'm far like this then your punch is
going to hurt
come closer it's not going to hurt can
they see it or maybe they use their
knees they can't really see you yeah
well maybe but yeah so that's what we
have it's like
this is the setup thing about that
usually you come up so the reaction is
like if i do this you react up fast
right
right yeah and then i come this i get
this
and then i get the the head and then i
lock the gate
and then i'm just gonna twist and turn
and sit on my butt yeah and it's gonna
go down
but if i if i really wanted to i could
just add my hip here and
i almost got flipped there wow they
couldn't hear any of this well they
could hear
they could hear it a little bit yeah wow
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
oh my gosh i love the strategy there
it's kind of like
pulling a little bit yeah i like that
that's good
um i'll go this way a little bit
okay that's good boom
boom jeez
it kind of is fun like the shot's nice
and like big now it's kind of cool
wide wide shot now yeah well we'll wrap
like this with the shot wide it looks
kind of cool
um it's super interesting because it's
like
with anything whether you go and shoot a
basketball 10
000 times or whether you write
40 books throughout your career whatever
you do
um in this case it's like in jiu jitsu
you're doing this
this under hook and you're practicing
that
under hook thousands of times and you're
becoming really good and really fast at
it and then submitting
the opponents and it's an
important thing to know is this close
quarters combat
it's an important exhilarating it's a
um in a way that you're not targeting
the hurt of others you're targeting
mastery
and like you were describing also
there's this sort of process where the
opponent in a sense is
is mirroring your vulnerabilities and
and they're
helping you become better like that i
think that's super cool way to putting
it so
yeah those were i already feel you know
a little bit of that you know for on the
on that side of the neck especially
you know and it's just like and you're
like wow i'm
this is just a game right now but this
[ __ ] really hurts even just like as a
as a play and that's not supposed to
hurt because that's just a throwing
thing right
it's not like there's submissions that
are meant to hurt right
if i if i were to land on that
with that with your head and arm locked
like that
i would do like a movement like this and
then that would be a head and arm choke
and then that will choke you out that
will
like eventually it cuts off circulation
to the brain
so that's more like a meant to hurt kind
of thing or
joint manipulations right arm bars and
things exactly yeah yeah
those are meant to hurt this wasn't
meant to hurt that was nothing exactly
there's nothing exactly
i love it okay wow
okay that's that's a wrap uh and we have
uh
like like we did our we did our nice
great demo at the end as well
i love that i'm glad we did that we got
our hypnosis demo
we got to unpack the warrior champion
mindset
i loved it it was great um
the human development that was awesome
just the stages of consciousness
development were great
adelie to montero thank you for coming
on the show thank you so much this has
been
this is so fun this is super
ridiculously fun i've loved every moment
of it it's been so nice
it's been super enriching i hope for
everyone as well that you guys have had
a good time
let us know your thoughts in the
comments below on the episode we'd love
to hear from you
like the video subscribe if you haven't
already go and check out alita's channel
she has a bunch of content on her
channel as well about the things that
she was teaching about on the program
there are also some other uh links in
the bio below
we have the uh instagram profile for
adelita go and check that out as well go
and follow her
her content is really inspiring i share
a lot of it myself
and then uh the arelita montero live.com
link to her website where she has a
bunch of this also
unpacked in uh more detail on there
and practice that warrior champion
mindset everyone practice it as you
manifest your dreams into the world
practice that
and support the other artists
entrepreneurs spiritual leaders
scientists engineers around the world
that you believe and support them and
help them flourishing in sports
simulation
our links are in the bio below to
support us
help us flourish i love that
what a great show warrior champion
mindset
that's it simulation i love it
707 that's a magic seven it's a very
magic number
it's a super magic number thank you
super powerful episode
thanks everyone much love thanks for
tuning in
see you soon ciao ciao peace
you